as we get to do more with Roseanne Barr
you get back in TV sitcom we'll only if
there's nudity and you're gonna be the
the nude person oh yeah
but so far they refused so far there I
don't know if you get that on a network
show anyway but I think in YouTube you
can do whatever you want I just like
talking to people and discussing what do
y'all think of this what should we do
how can we make this better obviously
cared enough cuz you ran for president
twice right I mean yeah and obviously
you care a lot about these issues but
you you're right your politics have
changed dramatically yeah and cuz I read
more like what changed you what what
what books what what shifted your
political views well my experience in
the green partying in socialist parties
I just felt very marginalized there and
that I didn't belong because they don't
like Israel and I was like what this is
the worst place on earth I've been there
have you been there oh yeah supporter of
Israel on television no you are yeah
it's a wonderful place with problems
like every place else I'd put a lot of
thinking into solution I just say I do a
lot of drinking I mean thinking and I
have a solution for it and it is I I've
always been saying this for like 20
years I think that if grandmother's from
Arab grandmothers Jewish grandmothers
Druze grandmothers everyone who lives
over there and grandmas if we could get
together and write up a grandma's treaty
and then present it to power I think
that'd be the fastest way to solving
problems because there's no children
there's no child on this earth that
should go to sleep in fear and danger
and hungry we had enough money to do we
have enough everything except love so I
I'm a evil in the world you kind of
rejected that earlier but I wrote a
whole book about that evil I'll send it
to you I know you did whoever was from
evil well mine was what that you know
how people I say get ready
hey get rid of your hate but you're
supposed to hate evil you know I have an
idea and I'm just gonna throw it out at
ya as I listen to you I think you
obviously a very sincere and saying I
want to have a conversation we need to
and I think the country's never been
this divided and it's stupid because we
got to get our money back from both
sides yeah we talked to me yeah yeah you
should go you know rosanne and friend
show and what you should do is your
standup yeah and then invite a guest and
have a real conversation I think that
would sell out in theaters all around
the country and I think it would be good
an invite Valerie Jarrett to go with you
I would do that because we could turn
this into a really great teachable
moment where there's a lot of synthesis
because that's why you have conversation
so that you can synthesize your ideas
that come up with a solution and I'm
tired of no solutions Sean that's why I
like Trump because I think he's the
solution we have a lot of the country
has gotten dramatically better and I
actually said on the air I think if he
cured cancer yeah at this point and gave
every American 30 million dollars they
be they still hate him but I think
they're coming around
you know stuff's going up his approvals
you seem to have had a really tough
brutal I haven't asked you about Tom
Arnold yet you still love him in a lot
of ways or no huh do I did you say do I
still love him apparently not he call
you now health no no that's that's 25
years ago that's two husbands ago sure
sorry how many total I'm sorry I'm not
keeping up I'm on my fourth one this
one's my longest one sixteen years I
still likes me but he does I heard he
couldn't caught you smoking and you hide
it well because I wore the rubber gloves
and a hat and I go out in the alley you
know and then I didn't know he didn't
smell it
I'd be wiping a few wild rose buds on me
and know he didn't know and I lied and
so on top of all this other stuff yeah
so he
opens up the Yahoo and there I am
smoking in my mom's alley and he came in
he goes because he knew you know that
I'd kill him if he made me mad
Oh sweetheart yeah you lied you lied to
me ouch about smoking didn't you would
you say here's the question I have in
all my years on television they've been
controversies yeah recently Samantha be
she still has her show
yeah when Bill Maher got fired at ABC I
said I'm not in favor of boycotts
I think people when they make mistakes
have a right people I think the American
people are fair I think the American
people are good
forget the media forget the people that
writes that I don't I think that's why
they turn into my show 28 million yeah
because they wanted to see something
balanced for once so every other show
it's like 24/7 hatin on Trump and I call
it hate reott ISM that's not gonna help
nothing mmm people want to hear the
balance that they want to hear the truth
and anything that isn't based on facts
and data and it's pure emotion that
ain't right so would you so you're gonna
do stand-up maybe you can enter your
standup serious that's part of it right
dude do you stand up then you sit down
and have a conversation with somebody
maybe you disagree with Shawn I gotta
tell you one thing for you kick me out
of here I'm not kicking you out you
could stay as long as you want I really
appreciate you being such a good friend
to me through when I was hiding in my
mom's basement remember and I found
cigarette butts from when I was 13 and I
used to smoke and they were damn good
smoking you spoke to him again all these
years later yeah they were good I
remember when cigarettes for 50 cents a
pack that's how old I am
no they were 27 okay you're much older
than me then yeah but I thank you for
the friendship and you helped me through
it a lot so do a lot of other people I
wanted people I guess thank you so much
for walking with me when I was like in a
in a real down place thank you